hello and welcome to swipe coming up the
children getting their hands dirty with
raspberry pi it goes on and on the
latest in the apple vs samsung court
battle the tech world's april fools and
you've got to be kidding the game that
lets you experience life as a goat this
week the government was criticized again
by a group of mps for the way it's
delivering broadband to rural areas yet
just last month Ofcom announced the UK
led the pack in superfast broadband
coverage against the e use five biggest
economies so just how well-connected are
people who live in the countryside I've
been investigating it's the sort of
thing that was familiar in the days of
dial-up waiting long enough for
something to download from the internet
you've time to make a cup of tea in this
particular instance when the coal gets
back to her laptop nothing has even
loaded I downloaded the latest fashion
of iOS at home that took around three
hours our average speed is half a
megabit per second the children have
difficulty researching their homework
particularly if we want to show them
short recordings of things are accessing
information government information
county council information a lot of
that's directly through internet sites
it's very difficult working from home
banking is hard you'd think Nicole's
rural village really was in the middle
of nowhere but six miles that way is the
end of the tube line into central London
and two miles this way is another rural
village that is on superfast broadband
across the country I have similar
stories via Twitter in Wiltshire a
downloader just over one megabit in
Lincolnshire half a megabit but five
miles away speeds of over 50
up in Lancashire they've taken it into
their own hands and they're digging
trenches to lay fiber to the home the
not for profit network barn has laid 500
kilometres of plastic ducting and
connected about four hundred households
common speeds and 90 megabits a second
on Wi-Fi and 900 via ethernet but
knowing if you should be setting up your
own line or waiting for the
government-funded service is a postcode
lottery the UK has been split into 44
areas for broadband delivery some like
northamptonshire have a detailed map
using postcodes so you know when to
expect the taxpayer-funded service other
areas have nothing at all or very basic
information so you've no idea if the
line will stop in the village next door
the rollout is being managed by BDUK and
they've been criticised for handing all
the contracts to one company BTW they
are so secretive about the maps which
would show actually which households
will be covered by the rollout of
superfast broadband so people in rural
communities can't make alternative
provision which they're anxious to do to
ensure they access that broadband BTW
say more maps will be released once
surveys of being completed the
government's target is 24 megabits per
second for ninety percent of the country
and a minimum speed of 2 megabits for
the final ten percent but even if they
reach these figures some will still need
convincing that could be that the green
cabinet at that your connect your
telephone line is connected to has been
enabled for fiber services but actually
you live too far away from it to benefit
in the meantime nicole will continue to
work from home by actually working from
her friend's house 10 minutes drive away
the living example of the digital divide
between rural and urban areas you're
watching swype coming up text most
vicious patent war is back but first
what do you think of when I say the
words Raspberry Pi if you're thinking of
pastry and fruit then think again it is
this a computer what does it do well the
short answer is lots Doug and has
been to meet the inventors of the future
at london science museum if the idea of
inventing something scares you meet this
fearless bunch item is what it's made of
and whether it's recyclable these
children and young people have been
using the Raspberry Pi a credit card
sized computer to make inventions to
help the environment this is PI park
it's a smart parking sense that we've
developed using the Raspberry Pi the
rostra pi is monitoring the car park to
check whether the spaces are vacant or
occupied when we were looking at
different ideas we came up with quite a
few dif this one seemed like the most
plausible and sensible it looks like fun
but there is a serious message here as
well a desire to teach young people
about technology like this from a young
age not just how to use computers but
how to build them we see a lot of
children now who use technology but
don't actually have the skills to create
new ideas bring new ideas to life so we
want to be more to to do that so I don't
think it's important for our economy
it's important for us
the next generation are the creators of
new ideas and just uses in others ideas
the organizers of this event are not
alone in that desire the hour of code
campaign is pushing for coding to be
taught in every school around the world
in the UK the national curriculum is
being changed so computer science will
be taught in all schools from sep tember
submitted another 50 being available on
the winners here some as young as 9
years old came up with inventions to
help you recycle care for plants prevent
forest fires and reduce car emissions
the judges say the kind of enthusiasm on
show here bodes well for the future the
ecosystem around teaching children to
code has flourished in the last couple
of years more and more organizations are
popping up that can teach children at
different age ranges and different
experience levels as well so I think
more is being done and I think we'll see
we'll soon see the effects about yeah
this was our first one then we did this
design
and who knows these young inventors
could be the tech stars of the future
now these kids are using a piece of pie
making it look like a piece of cake
Stewart Duggan Sky News you're watching
swype coming up the Amazon reaches your
living room but first it seems one trial
wasn't enough Apple and Samsung are in
court again here's Tom Cheshire where
the user friendly guide on the latest
billion-dollar lawsuit the Punch and
Judy battle between Apple and Samsung is
continuing there's a fresh court case
brought by Apple against Samsung saying
that the South Korean manufacturer has
stolen many of the features from the
iphone we've heard this before two years
ago Apple sued Samsung successfully for
a billion dollars this time Apple is
looking for two billion dollars which is
a much larger amount in these sorts of
cases and it's also seeking to get
samsung phones stop being sold because
of this infringement what they say now
this battle has raged around the world
in the EU and in the UK currently this
is on apple's home turf though in
Silicon Valley in San Jose samsung isn't
taking it lying down there saying that
actually Apple is motivated by a war
with Google who make the software that
runs on samsung phones and that this is
a proxy war this is Apple trying to have
a go at Google so the trials just
started expected to run until early May
but it could get messy you're watching
swype coming up the 2d shooter set in
World nura one but first here's a
roundup of anything you might have
missed over the last few days amazon has
found a way into the living room and
launched an internet-connected TV
set-top box amazon fire TV is well it's
a small black box it'll cost about fifty
nine pounds and is available now in the
States the device can also be used for
gaming after they partnered with Sega EA
and Disney the move puts amazon in
direct combat
edition with Apple TV and Google's
chromecast the european parliament has
voted to end of roaming charges the
regulation also guarantees an open
internet for all so called net
neutrality it means from December next
year the cost of making a call or
downloading internet data in another EU
country will be the same as at home
Vodafone is opening a hundred and fifty
new shops over the next year the company
wants to reduce its reliance on third
parties like Carphone Warehouse they say
the 1 billion pound investment will
create 1,400 jobs it is really a neat i
would call a customer experience because
it is a combination of the quality of a
network the quality of the products and
services that we offer and then last but
certainly not least it is the preferably
face-to-face interaction with with our
staff we do a great job in helping our
customers set up phones and transfer
contacts and help them use let's say
smartphones and tablets in an integrated
way so it's really all about customer
experience now how about going from this
to just this night vision contact lenses
are a step closer after researchers in
the u.s. created a material that absorbs
infrared rays at room temperature
current night vision technology needs
bulky cooling equipment but the graphene
based models can do the same job using
just a few layers of the atom thick
material but if you're a budding spy
don't get too excited there's still more
research needed on light sensitivity and
getting it to work in a broader range of
temperatures it's that time of the year
for pranks April Fool's Day plenty of
technology gags out there my favorites
if you find typing tiring why not use a
joystick to control the robots have done
what you know us Google Japan brings you
the magic hands or perhaps you could try
out Swift keys flow hard what people
don't know is we actually started
working on this a long way back but the
hover at the time just wasn't up to the
job and was taken until now quick catch
up
and finally personal aggregation
magazine Flipboard goes into gaming with
flappy bored the goal the game is simple
get through as many obstacles as
possible without letting flappy be crash
into anything mm I wonder where they got
the inspiration for that from talking of
games time to have a look at some of the
latest games releases with kezule
McDonald the biggest game out this week
is Elder Scrolls online which has been
in development for more than five years
it's basically Bethesda's oblivion
Skyrim Elder Scrolls series but in a
multiplayer RPG online the thing that's
a bit weird about the Elder Scrolls
online is that it's half MMO and a half
Elder Scrolls RPG so it's half quite
standard leveling quite basic combat but
then also half exploration and
self-directed stories the two things
don't quite mesh together as well as
they could but this is an MMO it's only
just out it's going to get lots better
the one thing that the Elder Scrolls
online has above other MMOs like at the
moment Guild Wars Warcraft it looks
pretty very pretty it's got that
Bethesda semi realism it's also got just
tons and tons of quests you know content
to do ms if there's a game that's going
to keep busy all year then it's going to
be this one go simulators started off as
a joke and it still as a joke but now
it's a joke you can buy for 699 it's
very throw away there's not an enormous
I mean basically if you think of Grand
Theft Auto and then add a goat and lots
of explosions then essentially you have
goat simulator you can lick stuff to
make it explode or you can attach
yourself by your goatee tongue to moving
objects to fling yourself around the
world the physics are insane it's a
patently ridiculous sandbox destruction
game it's very fun not for all that long
but it is extremely fun well
if you think about an old-school arcade
game like asteroids luftrausers is that
but times about a million it's
ridiculously frenetic at casio is a tiny
plane in a massive screen of total
carnage and destruction the main tension
is between shooting stuff and take
attempts to put out fires and repair
yourself you always making decisions
every millisecond ability decision its
proper old-school arcade eat which
gaming and it's really really well done
perfectly balanced and ready for battle
tera fall is like pixel art competitive
archery in and stay with me it's really
really good in single player is not
enormously compelling but in multiplayer
the way that the game works just makes
it so extremely competitively fun there
are things you can do a little tricks
you can grab arrows out of the air you
got only have a certain number of hours
you have to fetch them for any level
there's the platforming element of
moving around inside the 2d geometry as
just every single match seems to come
down to that one millisecond where
you're like no and then it's all over
it's really really fun with four players
as special
batman arkham origins blackgate is
really hard to say it's a spin off from
the Batman Arkham trilogy that's already
happened so basically it's a 2d version
where you return to the asylum after the
events of batman arkham origins so this
particular batman game came out in vita
in 3ds last year it's now being released
on pc eps and all the playstation and
xbox consoles is not enormously good
it's not bad but it's not enormously
good either it's kind of a 2d Metroid II
exploration game but the combat that is
so great in the proper back the big boy
batman games just doesn't really
translate all that well the exploration
is a lot of backtracking without an
enormous amount of like incentivization
I found it plotted quite a bit this is
shaping up to be a long night so let's
spend it together
that's it for this week remember you can
catch up with the breaking tech stories
all week on Sky News for iPad our
smartphone app and of course sky news
com bye-bye